it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning the home office and the Home
Secretary are undermounting pressure the
prison's Watchdog has found feelings at
the manston migrant processing center
where it says people are being held too
long and deteriorating and overcrowded
conditions in a somewhat combative
Commons appearance soell Ibraham and
denied that she's to blame but has
attracted more criticism for using the
word Invasion to characterize those
Channel Crossings in a couple of months
we'll be speaking to the immigration
Minister Robert General it is Tuesday
the 1st of November
get a grip the home office is warned by
the inspectorate of Prisons over
failings at the manston migrant
processing center
it seems to me that some of those risks
we highlighted in in the summer have
materialized and and things seem to have
got much much worse
I'm live in
conditions inside are described as
desperate
Dalton secretary Sue Ella Bravo is
accused used of using far-right rhetoric
to defend herself and her policies
also there's a more bumper BP profits
are expected when the energy giant
announces its latest quarterly results
one cues for water in Keys as Russian
forces bombard civilian infrastructure
[Music]
morning all the home office has been
told to get a grip on problems at the
manston migrant processing center in
Kent which are said to be getting worse
are reports from the inspectorate of
Prisons found failing sent the
overcrowded facility including detainees
not being allowed to fully close toilet
doors and being forced to sleep on the
floor
it's designed to hold 1 600 people but
there are currently about four thousand
detained there that's more than any
prison in the UK the Watchdog went there
in July and released its report about
the visit this morning it also saw that
people weren't allowed access to mobile
phones to speak to family while
detainees described as exhausted waited
long periods to be processed
we were complementary about the things
that had gone well but we highlighted a
number of risks uh that we felt the home
office needed to pick up on it seems to
me that some of those risks we
highlighted in in the summer have
materialized and and uh things seem to
have got much much worse it apparently
they are overwhelmed by the numbers of
people that they've got there at the
moment and they're simply not processing
them through which means that families
children
are sleeping or mats on the floor when
they should be in proper accommodation
very pleased to say joining us in the
studio the immigration Minister Robert
Minister lovely to see you good morning
um look I I do think it is to your
credit that you have personally visited
at manston describe what you saw when
you did well good morning conditions are
poor at the site they are improving we
are trying to ensure that as many people
as possible leave the site to better
accommodation mostly in hotels as
quickly as possible you have to remember
this site is designed for around one to
two thousand people it's a site where
people are brought to very soon after
they're saved at sea or on beaches by
border force and Royal Navy personnel
they're then taken to Dover give an
immediate care in extremists and then
brought to this site where they're
processed they're given some supports
and medical care and then they're taken
on to better accommodation it's not
designed to be somewhere where people
stay for a prolonged period of time it
is by necessity relatively austere the
task for us now is to ensure that it
gets back to its normal working pattern
it has a population of around a thousand
or two thousand and we don't get into
this situation again but did you see as
the the the HM inspector report shows
did you see people sleeping on Floors
did you see evidence of people including
children being detained for longer than
24 48 hours did you see people not being
allowed to use the toilet without the
door being open
I didn't see what you just described
about about toilets there are people
there who stayed for over 24 hours and
sleeping on the floor there are people
sleeping on the floor on mats like
camping mats this is not a satisfactory
situation I'm not here to to defend that
I've been in this role for less than a
week and my job is to sort situations
like this out and improve them and that
is exactly what we're doing we have
procured more hotels very rapidly and
more are coming on board literally every
day so that individuals can leave this
site we've also put in place better
conditions there so for example there is
now a very good Medical Center at the
site providing care for people
particularly for the families that are
there I would just say that the root
cause of what we're seeing at Mountain
is not the government but it's certainly
not the brilliant border force staff who
are managing the site the contractors
the catering stuff the problem is that
thousands of people are crossing the
channel illegally and every day are
landing at Dover
to know how to support them because our
Asylum system was not designed to
receive thousands of people every day
illegally indeed and we will discuss
that in a second but but simply put is
manston fit for purpose
yes I think it is uh it's not operating
correctly today if we can get it back
down to a population of around double
capacity a thousands it's running at
Double capacity at the moment people are
sleeping on the floors and they're being
detained you're asking me is it fit for
purpose yes it was fit for purpose a
matter of weeks ago the issue is there
are just far too many people staying
there today if we can get the site back
down to what it was designed for which
is one to two thousand people staying
for a very short period of time around
24 hours then going on to better
accommodation then it will once again be
fit for purpose but the problem there is
a task to handle the problems were
identified by staff there as early as
July and probably before that as the
inspector report makes clear back in
July there were Asylum Seekers being
crowded into the facility there were
people sleeping on mats there were
people being prevented on going into the
fresh air why did it take three petrol
bombs and a suicide for this government
to actually fess up that there was a
problem there and start trying to do
something about it now it's nothing to
do with the and you shouldn't trivialize
what happened
that had nothing to do with what we're
seeing at manston in fact the decision
for that individual to attack the the
Western jet foil at Dover actually made
this issue significantly worse because
rightly we evacuated all of the migrants
who had Dover brought them to Manchester
and that increased the population
what I can say is what I've done in
position and I've been in position for
less than a week I've visited I've met
the local Member of Parliament I've met
the border for staff there we're
procuring more hotels at pace so the
population of the site reduces I'm
hopeful that it will reduce every day of
this week that is dependent on the
number of migrants who cross the channel
because if you have a thousand migrants
illegally crossing the channel every day
we have to take them somewhere in the
moment and that that is to Manchester
you seem to be that makes it very
challenging at manston particularly in
terms of overcrowding I've only just
Arisen as the inspector reporting things
clear there were issues around
overcrowding even at even back in July
you're talking about procuring extra
hotels and that is fantastic but the
fact that you having just been in the
job for a handful of days are having to
do this suggests that when swella Braven
was asked in the House of Commons
yesterday whether she herself had
stopped the procurement of extra hotels
and she denied that well that suggests
that perhaps she wasn't being entirely
truthful no that's not correct more
hotels have been coming online almost
every month throughout the whole of this
year so swella Brotherman and her
predecessor pretty Patel were procuring
more hotels what I have done in my short
tenure is ramp that up and procure even
more because November historically has
been one of the highest months of the
year for migrants illegally crossing the
channel and so we have to be prepared
for that because quite rightly as a
country we want to treat migrants in the
most Humane and compassionate way
possible but it is worth saying the root
cause of the problem is the sheer number
of people choosing to make that
dangerous job immense pressure on our
system because we don't design the
system for 50 000 people plus to cross
the channel illegally twice every year
compared to them as illegal immigrants
or on what basis given the fact that
that of those who seek asylum in this
country 75 of them are successful I
didn't call them illegal immigrants so
they're illegal migrants it is not legal
to cross the channel in a small boat the
individuals who arrive here invariably
not in every case claim Asylum and and a
large a large proportional majority
under our current system succeed but
also a significant proportion do not and
a number of the people I met for example
at Manson were from Albania a
demonstrably safe country they were
predominantly young males who were fit
healthy prosperous enough to pay the
people traffickers and members of the
public listening to this of course they
want the UK to uphold our proud
tradition of giving refuge for people
fleeing persecution and human rights
abuses but they will also be shocked
that so much pressure is being put on
this country by people who are here
essentially as economic migrants it
makes the point it's the language around
this is useful we have just as you
mentioned seen a very serious attack on
that processing at that Center in Dover
yesterday we had the the Home Secretary
describing this as an invasion on the
south coast I mean we do characterize it
like that well in a job like mine you
have to choose your words very carefully
and I would never demonize people coming
to this country in pursuit of a of a
better life and I understand and
appreciate Our obligation to refugees in
fact I've had for much of this year a
Ukrainian Refugee family it's staying
with me in my own why did she describe
it as an invasion when clearly it is not
well I'd say two things in response to
that firstly the scale of the challenge
we're facing is very very significant 50
000 people and the number could well be
significantly higher over the course of
this year is a major challenge for this
country and it is leading to the
infrastructure that we have in terms of
reception centers like manston in terms
of Hotel accommodation and Asylum and uh
social housing essentially being
overwhelmed was the Home Secretary wrong
to describe this as an invasion on the
south coast I think invasion is a way of
describing the sheer scale of the
challenge and that's what uh swella
Bravo was trying to express she was also
speaking I think and this is an
important point for those people who
live on the south coast who day in day
out are seeing migrant boats landing on
their beaches there was a report just
yesterday from a lady who found a young
migrant from Albania in her kitchen
seeking support asking for money that's
not acceptable in this country we wanted
to just come here no one is suggesting
that safely and legally through schemes
like the homes for Ukraine one the
Afghan scheme that the scheme in
Afghanistan or Hong Kong how do you get
here well you can apply for Asylum to
come to the United Kingdom but you do
not do that you don't well through
through one of those routes if you are
from Ukraine you don't Hong Kong you
don't do that by leaving a safe country
France I mean you've got let's just take
the albanians for an example
across the channel this year have come
from Albania that's a safe country
they've crossed multiple other safe
countries they've then left France one
of the safest countries that we Britain
you couldn't say imagine you can send
them and then they will be part of the
25 who feel but again you're describing
people as illegal migrants to this
country so Ella Bradman did it yesterday
when 75 of them are successful and
they're Simon can look it's a simple
question prima facie isn't it illegal
for anyone who has claimed Asylum to be
detained for longer than 24 hours uh you
should well you we do not have the right
to claim to detain anybody for more than
24 hours so acai have you been doing
that then well a site like Mansa needs
to operate within the law I have been
completely clear to my officials that's
what we must do but you're not we must
ensure that this site returns to not
just a legal way of operating but a
Humane and compassionate way as quickly
in this interview that people are
staying there for longer than 24 hours
why
the the pressures that have Arisen there
have because the sheer quantity of
people crossing the channel we didn't
design and this wasn't my responsibility
I've only been in the job for a week but
manston Manson was not designed for the
eventuality of 50 000 people crossing
the channel in small boats if you have a
week where the weather is favorable and
the tides are in the right direction you
could find five thousand people looking
to change illegal and you're trying to
dress up as a lasting capacity look I
had the Home Secretary yesterday
describing herself as the victim of a
political Witch Hunt on what basis is
that a fact well what I think is
important is not to be overly distracted
by some of the issues that the press and
the opposition have been reporting to
get to the nub of the issue facing the
country which is that we have a serious
crisis from illegal migration we don't
have a system that's currently set up to
deal with this number of people and we
need to change that to reduce it there's
a bit Rich for the Home Secretary to
complain that she is the victim of a
political witch on on the day that she
herself is forced to admit that she has
broken the main Studio code not once for
which she was sacked but six times when
she said that she made a mistake she
repeatedly made that mistake wasn't the
mistake that the Home Secretary made
getting caught sending emails from her
private account well the Home Secretary
accepted that she shouldn't have sent
those emails after she got shot she has
apologized after she got caught at the
time she offered her resignation as Home
Secretary it was accepted by the former
prime minister that was The Honorable
thing to do once once is a mistake sex
is a pattern of behavior well she's
apologized for doing that's enough she's
accepted that that was not the right
course
would you get sacked for undermining
your boss and then six days later be
back in post genuinely
well all I can say is that the Home
Secretary has apologized for sending
those emails I mean you do have to
remember that she was sending an email
which was not top secret it was an email
that should not have been sent in that
manner but you were sending to a fellow
parliamentarian a former security
minister
intelligence and security committee so
you know you one has to
um you you can't say this was a serious
breach of security it wasn't seriously
it was not enough for this Simon case
it was not the correct thing to do she's
apologized for that and now she's got a
big job to do as Home Secretary and my
job as her Deputy working alongside her
is to ensure that we get into a much
better place with migration so we can
have a system which welcomes the best
and the brightest from around the world
legally but clamps down on those people
who are coming here illegally because
that is not what the British public
wants they do not want to see scenes of
thousands of people crossing the channel
and and the reality is when those people
do that
they put immense pressure on our system
and makes it even harder to do what I
think you're you want us to do which is
to be opening and welcome to welcoming
to those people coming for real extreme
situations if manston is overcrowded if
social housing is taken up with
essentially economic migrants we can't
do our historic Duty as a country which
is to be a great compassionate country
for those who really are in need
illegal immigrants despite the fact that
75 of them get their Asylum claims
accepted well they shouldn't be crossing
the channel in small boats that you know
we we may disagree on that but I do not
think that people should be risking
their lives they shouldn't be paying
criminal gangs and they certainly
shouldn't be coming to this country like
some of the albanians we're seeing
purely as economic migrants or Worse to
commit criminality in my job is to clamp
down on that a quick look at the clock
and it's the ICF detain you for slightly
longer than I should but I haven't seen
you for a while so thank you very much
uh well let's turn our attention back of
course to to manston that's guys Ash
zahid is at the processing center there
um Aisha of course as we were just
hearing uh from the minister there are
concerns but they wish to try and sort
it out I mean what have you been hearing
from inside there
yeah well these findings from this
inspection that took place in July just
provide a wider scope of all the
problems here we learned about the
overcrowding we've heard of reports of
disease spreading here but uh this
highlights other key areas where uh
things are well and truly lacking the
inspectorate of Prisons uh say that
failings undermine the resilience to
deal with the increasing number of
migrants that are arriving here and it
led to the Chief Inspector of Prisons
Charlie Taylor saying that the home
office need to get a grip they need to
be quicker in their processing of the
migrants that arrive here now manston is
only designed as a short-term holding
facility people are expected to stay
here in theory for no more than 24 hours
it's only a place to get their paperwork
to begin the Asylum seeking a screening
process whilst there are facilities such
as water food areas to shower it isn't
residential but despite this people are
staying here for significantly longer
than those first 24 hours now this
report did find that as a short-term
accommodation or holding facility it
does the job but it detailed a number of
failings one of which was that a lot of
the space is actually out of use and
that comes down to a lack of staff there
were also signs of strain reported that
detainees were sleeping on the floor
some had been there for over 30 hours
and then when it came to more vulnerable
people trafficking victims people with
disabilities people with severe mental
health problems some of these people
were just not being assessed properly
and not being marked as adults at risk
in all cases there were also concerns
around dignity and Welfare their report
details that people weren't necessarily
allowed to use their mobile phones to
let their family members know that they
were safe they weren't allowed to close
doors when they were in the toilets and
also translation services weren't also
always being used to make sure that the
migrants understood what was happening
and the report also says that the risks
it understands from credible sources
um seem to have significantly
deteriorated from the time this
inspection took place back in July now
the home office have responded in a
statement and in that statement they've
said as a result of these numbers our
Asylum system has been put under
incredible strain but we recognize there
is more to do to provide alternative
accommodation for people arriving in the
UK Manson remains resourced and equipped
to process migrants securely and we will
provide alternative accommodation as
soon as possible now those numbers they
refer to are the increasing number of
Channel Crossings we're seeing but as a
result of the findings from this
inspection the inspectorate of prism
says that it will be coming back swiftly
to conduct another one and they hope to
see significant improvements made then
Aisha thanks very much indeed
do stick with us coming up on a very
busy show in a few minutes time I'll be
speaking to Charlie Taylor the Chief
Inspector in prisons at the moment
behind that report telling the home
office to get a grip over the mountain
Immigration Center in Kent
we'll also be speaking to Reese Davis
from the Independent monitoring
authority over claims that millions of
EU citizens could be deported due to the
government's interpretation of the
brexit withdrawal agreement
and as the Prime Minister and Chancellor
work away at their Autumn statement due
in two weeks I'll be asking the
resolution Foundation what we can expect
now let's turn our attention to Ukraine
now we're at residents of Kiev queued
for water after Russian strikes knocked
out water and power supplies
a massive balance of Russian cruise
missile and drone strikes hit critical
infrastructure in Kiev parkive and other
Ukrainian cities early on Monday
appears to be further retaliation for
what Russia says was a Ukrainian drone
attack on its Black Sea Fleet
meanwhile the UK is pledging more
support for Ukraine to defend its
cyberspace with a package worth more
than six million pounds it focuses on
Ukraine to defend its systems from
Russian hackers
I think we're already on the front line
I think we we are very aware that we
Face a very significant cyber threat
from Russia clearly we Face uh you know
if you look back to the screepile
poisoning in on the streets of Salisbury
we you know we Face a very significant
threat when it comes to that kind of
activity so I think we we are aware of
the threat
um we have raised our own preparations
and our own defensive that's why we've
got some deep uh expertise when it comes
to cyber defense and that's why we'd be
very pleased to share it with our
Ukrainian allies
just a reminder that tonight we have a
special program live from the Imperial
War Museum looking back at the war so
far that's Ukraine a modern war live on
Sky News from half past seven with Mark
Austin it will also be available on the
Sky News YouTube channel
uh some of the day's other headlines now
and Israel will today go to the polls
for the fifth time in less than four
years as former prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu looks to return to office now
despite Mr Netanyahu being on trial for
corruption charges which he denies his
party is projected to be the largest
after this election
police are looking for a gunman after
two men in their 20s died in a crash
following a car chase in South London
one was a takeaway driver who was
knocked off his motorbike the other was
shot dead by the driver of the second
car in the chase it is the second
shooting incident in London in five days
the trial begins today of a man and
woman accused of murdering their baby on
Christmas day in 2020. 10 month old
Finley boredom died in hospital after
being found unresponsive at an address
in Chesterfield
Stephen Borden and Shannon Marston
denied the charges against them
well in the last few minutes BP has
published its third quarter results and
they come in at 8.2 billion dollars and
the figure is down from the previous
quarter but more than double the same
time period in 2021 it is likely to add
to calls about a windfall tax on oil and
energy Giants joining us now to tell us
a little bit more on this our business
correspondent
lovely to see you this morning take us
through the figures yes 8.2 billion
dollars that was the headline figure
from BP this morning
the company's third quarter results down
slightly as you said from the previous
quarter but more than double the 3.3
billion dollars that it posted this time
last year now all of this just really
underscores just how well oil and gas
producers have been doing from rising
wholesale prices stoked in part of
course by the war in Ukraine BP's rival
shell last week also revealed a bumper
set of profits
um and all of this is only likely to
increase the pressure on the government
to expand the windfall tax that Rishi
sinak announced while Chancellor back in
May that additional 25 levy on the
profits of North Sea oil and gas
producers now uh BP uh this morning
revealed that it's paid an additional
778 million pounds towards that tax but
it's rival shell last week admitted that
it hasn't paid a penny in taxation
towards that tax primarily because it's
British corporate entity hasn't made a
penny of a penny of profit in the North
Sea because it's spent so much money uh
drilling now when Rishi sinach announced
that attacks he said that he hoped it
would contribute an extra 5 billion to
the public finances within its first
year
um there have been some calls for him to
expand that
um that windfall tax so that some of the
investment allowances are made less
generous and so that it's expanded to
include activities such as refining and
profits at Four Courts and that money
won't be snubbed at when you consider
the fact that the government is eyeing
up 50 billion pounds of uh tax Rises and
spending cuts to help repair the public
finances the oil companies have tacitly
accepted uh that they may have to pay
more tax Ben van burden Shell's chief
executive said last week
um that it was a societal reality uh
that uh oil and gas companies will have
to pay more tax and that the company was
in talks with the treasury so come
November the 17th
um when the government reveals its
latest budget don't be too surprised if
you see greater taxes for oil and gas
companies in there
good many thanks indeed
no China's strict covered restrictions
have led to the closure of Disney's
Shanghai Resort after a single visitor
tested positive all visitors must now
test negative before being allowed to
leave the park meanwhile there are
concerns that production of Apple's
iPhone could drop by 30 this month
following reports of factory workers
attempting to flee the facility and the
stringent covered measures surrounding
the area let's speak to our Asian
correspondent Helen Ann Smith who is in
Beijing good to see you Helen and um
this is yet another example of China
pursuing that that zero covert policy
well that's exactly it what's happened
in Shanghai Disneyland and what's
happened at the Apple iPhone Factory all
a sign of things that are happening
across China right now firstly that
covert cases are on the rise and that
means that caution paranoia anxiety
about it is also on the rise from the
authorities who of course as you as
you've just said there and people will
remember are aiming for that goal of
zero cover in this country but also from
the Chinese people who whenever they go
out to any shop or restaurant or bar to
Shanghai Disneyland or anywhere else
they run this Gauntlet that where they
are at there could have been a covert
case registered there the whole thing
gets shut down they get stuck inside and
there's very little they can do about it
until they test negative come and have a
look over here this is um a very
ubiquitous sign um in in China right now
the covert testing sites sites like this
are on the corner of almost every street
not just here in Beijing but across
China and people depending on what area
they live in have to get tested every
two to three days more often if you're
in a district that has higher levels
um of covid and and it's really just
part of daily life and if you test
positive that will mean extended periods
of lockdown what happened in Shanghai in
particular is worth noting because the
whole of the Disneyland site was shut
down because of one covert case a few
days prior and I think it's a sign of
just how nervous the authorities are
there is very Swift quite Draconian very
sweeping dramatic we would think action
taken over in that case just one case
that went to the to that site a couple
of days prior so real anxiety here worth
saying the numbers in China at the
moment we're looking at about 2 800 or
so covert cases per day which sounds
like really very very low numbers when
you consider the population here is 1.4
billion people but that's actually
double what the cases were just last
week and there are numbers that are
roughly what they were back in the
spring ahead of bigger outbreaks and
bigger lockdowns in Shanghai and other
places worth saying in terms of that
Apple Factory at the Foxconn Factory
what happened there a few cases the site
got locked down workers unable to leave
and there's all these videos emerging of
really horrible conditions inside that
factory and workers trying to leave to
escape to get back to their home
villages on foot largely for hundreds of
miles in some cases because there was no
transport so just signs of this system
really straining at the edges and
putting people in the authorities under
a lot of pressure
Helena thanks a lot
let's have a look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
and we certainly windy overnight and
it's going to continue to be very windy
at times this week widespread showers
and more General rain as well it will
turn cooler as we lose that warming
southerly wind
looking to be fairly mild and windy at
first today with Gales in your channel
Coast prolonged rain clearing through
Northeastern Britain and showers to the
South and to the West the morning will
stay windy with early rain over
Northeastern Britain becoming confined
to the far north and blustery showers
spreading from the southwest
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
an extended period of instability and
security especially one resulting from a
series of catastrophic events what am I
talking about it is perhaps unsurprising
that this is the definition of 2022's
word of the Year Perma crisis it's born
out of just how truly awful 2022 has
been for so many people are calling
according to the Collins Dictionary it's
also a new addition to the dictionary
along with partygate and Vibe shift
that's a new one on me which describes a
significant change in the prevailing
atmosphere or culture I'm sure plenty of
you have your own words to describe the
past 12 months coming up after the break
is the pressure mounts on Sue Ella
bravaman over the manston Immigration
Center I'll be speaking to the head of
the inspector of Prisons who's told the
home office to get a grip
[Music]
uh welcome back let's bring you just a
little bit more on our lead story this
morning the immigration Minister Robert
generick telling the program that the
root cause of the problems at that
processing center for migrants was the
number of people crossing the channel in
small boats but it did appear to
criticize his boss the Home Secretary
swella Braverman for the language that
she used in the House of Commons
yesterday when she claimed that Asylum
Seekers were engaged in an invasion of
the south coast
in a job like mine you have to choose
your words very carefully and I would
never demonize people coming to this
country in pursuit of a of a better life
and I understand and appreciate Our
obligation to refugees in fact I've had
for much of this year a Ukrainian
Refugee family staying with me in my own
why did she describe it as an invasion
when clearly it is not well I'd say two
things in response to that firstly the
scale of the challenge we're facing is
very very significant 50 000 people and
the number could well be significantly
higher over the course of this year is a
major challenge for this country and it
is leading to the infrastructure that we
have in terms of reception centers like
manston in terms of Hotel accommodation
and Asylum and social housing
essentially being overwhelmed was the
Home Secretary wrong to describe this as
an invasion on the south coast I think
invasion is a way of describing the
sheer scale of the challenge and that's
what uh swella Bravo was trying to
express
as you can see tomorrow going back in
the studio good to see you this morning
um like I don't want to put thoughts
into Mr generic's head or words into his
mouth but it strikes me that that was
not a wholehearted approval of what the
Home Secretary said in the House of
Commons yesterday no he clearly doesn't
approve of what she said and made clear
that he would never he as he put it
demonize people who've come to this
country for a better life he also said
in that interview that while hotels had
been procured every month this year
under Sue Ella bravman and her
predecessor pretty Patel thought he used
his language quite carefully there he
didn't say whether she had followed
every bit of advice but said hotels
would procured every month he said he
had now ramped that up as a result of
what he saw at manston on Sunday only of
course three days into his job as
immigration minister so clearly there is
the ability to ramp it up and he is now
doing that and the impression being
created is clearing up a mess someone at
the home office told me yesterday that
the system had been gunned up by failure
to get enough hotel rooms for the large
numbers of people 38 000 people have
crossed the channel this year on small
boats and clearly there was a decision
or there was a failure to get enough
hotel rooms to get those people um out
of the Manson processing center and into
a more secure accommodation he is now
ramping that up and the impression that
many conservatives are getting is that
he is fixing a mess Sue Ella brought
them in the Home Secretary still in
trouble I think both over this and over
the business of sending emails from her
personal account victim of a political
Witch Hunt tomorrow come on well she's a
very strong language in the Commons
yesterday including actually accusing
other politicians of using inflammatory
language but she didn't answer some of
the more detailed questions put to her
by the opposition I think many
conservatives are just waiting to see
what else may come out there Robert
generic seems like a safe Pair of Hands
in the number two position at the home
office and I think there's still
speculation about whether there might be
further changes to Rishi cnx top team
may well be at Matt thanks very much but
of course coverage of the home office
and indeed the Home Secretary dominates
this morning's papers alarm at
braverman's immigration rhetoric that's
the headline today for the times
the mail courts the Home Secretary
describing the migrant crisis as out of
control
the eye describes as fighting for her
political life over allegations of
inhumane conditions at migrant
facilities and of course as Tamara was
mentioning her handling of emails
containing sensitive information
uh same story for the guardian
unsurprisingly their headline bravaman
increases the refugee rhetoric as
pressure to quit grows
and the Metro Pictures three children at
the manston center in Kent their
headline welcome to the UK
uh well appropriately enough we do have
in the studio with us the Chief
Inspector of Prisons who took a look at
manskin Charlie Taylor Charlie great to
have you this morning
um let's just start with the with the
the basic facts here what did you
discover uh through your visits to the
manston center is it in your view and I
put this question to Robert generic
earlier is it in your review fit for
purpose well we visited originally in
the summer and though we had a number of
criticisms that we made of of the center
actually it was generally functioning
reasonably well as was Western jet foil
at Dover where migrants arrive off the
boats I then returned in September to
have another look and already we were
beginning to see some of those risks
that we'd flagged up in the summer
manifest themselves so people were
starting to spend longer on site people
were unable to make contact with family
people were staying in accommodation
that wasn't good enough what we're now
hearing is is that things have become
much worse that people are spending much
longer periods of time at the center and
uh and and that I've announced that we
will go back and reinspect in the near
future when you say that the
accommodation is unacceptable just just
to explain exactly what you mean by this
I mean ultimately this is a site at
which people are supposed to be spending
no longer than 24 48 hours that's right
it's a short-term holding facility and
that means people should come in they
should be quickly processed and they
should move on to suitable accommodation
what's happening at Manson when I
visited was people were sleeping on the
floors on on their rubber mats down on
the floors and then very thin blankets
or mattresses lots and lots of people in
a room
um all squished in together uh very
uncomfortable the the room for families
uh has lots and lots of different
families all sharing the same room uh
very young children older children uh
and some and for a few hours that would
be acceptable but where people are
spending long periods of time there it
just isn't what about the health
concerns that there are on site we've
had reports of cases of Scabies of
diphtheria of MRI AC I mean all of that
is it must be troubling to you as well
well it's inevitable if if you put
people together in very close proximity
for long periods of time particularly
people who've come from parts of the
world where perhaps they haven't had the
opportunity to have vaccines uh
unfortunately the risk is that things
like scabies or diphtheria will appear
personally in your position and I know
this because my grandfather actually
worked in the inspector for Education
you have to choose your language very
very carefully when you tell the home
office that they need to get a grip on
this situation that sounds to me like
the strongest criticism that someone in
your position can possibly make we'll be
back we'll be back at the center we'll
be looking to see an improvement in in
treatment and conditions of the
detainees who are there and yes they
need to get a grip is this situation
solvable is it fixable and if so how I
think it is fixable
um providing suitable accommodation for
people uh making sure that the processes
that happen in manston are efficient
that they're streamlined that there are
enough staff enabled in order to do that
now there are many complications it's a
difficult site to run but we've seen it
operating pretty well when we were there
in the summer so this is doable but for
whatever reason things seem to have
unraveled more recently just just in
terms of of the day job and you go
you're in and out of Prisons up and down
this country comparing manston to to you
know your average prison the idea that
someone can't use the toilet without
having the door open at the idea that
people are not being having access to to
Fresh Air I mean it strikes me that
those are things that would be
unacceptable and rarely to be found in
the prison system I would be horrified
if I went into a prison where prisoners
didn't have mattresses where prisoners
didn't have flushing lavatories where
prisoners didn't have uh telephones that
they could stay in touch with family and
friends those are three things that we
see at Manson similarly if they couldn't
get out into the fresh air and of course
one thing that you don't find in the
well in in mainstream prisons you find
in young offenders institutions young
people just a just a word from you on
the way in which they're being treated
we had anecdotally you know one child
had been detained there for for longer
than 40 well for 48 hours other children
are as you mentioned sleeping on the mat
I mean that in and of itself should be
enough to to prompt a government into
action it it's extremely concerning that
children are being asked to sleep on the
floor in a combination that's that's
wholly wholly unsuitable and bear in
mind that some of these people have had
incredibly long Journeys some of them
are potentially victims of torture
victims of all sorts of abuse and also
potentially victims of trafficking as
well and the idea that we then expect
them to sleep on the floor for long
periods of time just is not acceptable
so what happens next from your position
what is the time scale that the home
office has to get this sorted out and if
it doesn't and you mentioned you're
going back into to see what happens and
if it doesn't improve what is the
following step well we we will we will
return to the site we we won't announce
when that will be we'll return to the
site we will expect to see substantial
changes in in what's happening there
we'll expect to see migrants moving on
more quickly to suitable accommodation
and that many of the things that we've
flagged up in this report in terms of uh
seeking out people with vulnerabilities
making sure the victims of torture are
identified making sure translation
services are in place we'll be going
back and we're looking for those things
if we don't see an improvement there
we'll we will raise our future concerns
Charlie honest question I mean have you
seen anything like it before
it's a it's a real worry now we were
there earlier in the year when things
were not so bad so we haven't been back
to inspect recently we will go back and
see but what we're hearing from a number
of very credible sources so Roger Gale
um from Dave Neal from the inspector of
the boys uh from trade unions who are
working there but things are going wrong
at Manson and as I said before the home
office I need to get a grip Charlie
Taylor great to have you in the studio
this morning really appreciate it
no millions of chickens turkeys and
other birds must be kept inside or
covered in England from next week all
because of of course that outbreak of
bird flu which the chief vet has said is
the worst ever now apart from the
potential impact on your Christmas
turkey the virus is cutting through wild
bird populations after little respite
over the summer our Science and
Technology editor Tom Clark reports
it's the equivalent of lockdown for
anything with feathers keepers of birds
across England now have just seven days
to house their animals the rules the
same for large free-range flocks and
hobbyist hen Keepers alike
this is the worst bird for the epidemic
we've seen with multiple protection
zones in place across the UK
a compulsory housing order was already
in place for East Anglia with the
highest number of cases but with new
outbreaks continuing from next Monday
the housing order will be extended to
cover the rest of England
here at the perbrite institute in Surrey
scientists are analyzing every new
sample of the h5n1 virus that's causing
the outbreak
first emerged in farm birds in China in
1996.
the conclusion with just a few genetic
mutations it's evolved from a disease of
poultry into one which infects wild
birds which then reinfect farmed flocks
allowing it for the first time to
persist between outbreaks the migratory
bird before that come and go but now in
the summer the virus remain in the UK
and persisting and therefore this virus
is more dangerous in that term for the
poultry compared to the previous viruses
is it fair to say we're looking at a
different virus a different h5n1 than we
were before
that's right so those viruses were
different than this one
given how rapidly bird flu is changing
in order to stay on top of the current
outbreak and have any hope of preventing
future ones the scientists here are
having to work constantly to understand
the evolution of the virus
which flu vaccine like the one they're
developing here could break the cycle of
infection between farmed and wild birds
but trade rules currently prohibit their
use this epidemic May force a rethink
Tom Clark Sky News
now heads are down at the treasury as
the Prime Minister and the chancellor of
course prepare for their delayed Autumn
statements now due on the 17th of
November but new research by the
resolution Foundation suggests just the
starkness of the fiscal challenge facing
them and indeed what can be expected to
fill that black hole our very pleased
this evening speak now to James Smith
the resolution foundation's research
director James great to have you on the
program this morning just tell us
exactly what you have been discovering
well good morning yes so the as you say
that the Prime Minister has been very
clear that the central task for the
Autumn statement on the 17th of November
is really to re-establish The
credibility of the government's Economic
Policy so that's basically to get the
public finances in order now there's
really two things that are making that
difficult for them the the new
government and that's basically that the
economy is weaker so we think the obr
the office for Budget responsibility the
physical Watchdog is going to forecast a
recession going to knock something like
two to four percent of the size of the
economy that means the Outlook is more
difficult and on top of that the legacy
of the Liz trust government so by that I
mean something like 17 billion of tax
cuts that are still out there and higher
interest rates basically means that the
task is is a big one so the the
chancellor and the Prime Minister
basically have to find something like 40
billion in savings and that's just going
to mean that just spending cuts alone
aren't going to do it we're also going
to need tax cuts and that's the sort of
mood music that we're starting to hear
from the Prime Minister yeah yeah and
not just from the Prime Minister a
well-placed treasury Source appease to
have briefed most of the right-wing
press this morning that tax tax Rises
are coming and there are going to be tax
Rises across the board I mean does that
fit with your modeling yeah so and I
mean to find 40 billion of savings or to
to bring the fiscal position to into the
sustainable place there's four options
they can cut back on the investment
spending that uh Boris Johnson I promise
you can reintroduce something like
austerity so really hitting day-to-day
spending for government departments
really hard you can uh you can end up
raising taxes or you can cut benefits so
these are four very unappealing options
it's hard to see how big and Lincoln
reduce borrowing by more than about 20
billion by slashing the departmental
spending so we think they're going to
need to do something on taxes as well
that could be a
reinstatement of Richie sunax Health and
Social care Levy that's the biggest
thing here but if they don't do that
they might end up having to do quite a
few things in terms of uh tax Rises just
to try and balance the books isn't it
possible given given the Improvement
that was seen in guilts and bonds isn't
it possible for the country to grow its
way out of this
so the the Fallen interest rates we've
seen will definitely help and we've seen
we saw a huge spike in government
borrowing costs following the the mini
budget that's now fallen back down so
the amount that uh the UK was paying to
borrow relative to other countries that
has fallen back to where it was since uh
roughly at the time of the mini budget
but uh longer term Rises since the
summer since Boris Johnson resigned are
still there so that's going to cost the
government something like 10 billion in
in terms of increased power and then on
top of that Global interest rates have
been been rising uh across countries and
that's another 10 billion so the
environment is unfavorable uh we think
the the growth forecasts are going to be
very weak they could even be a recession
as I say and that basically means that
um all this will make it even harder for
the for the Prime Minister and the new
government to bring the public finances
into a sustainable station
and and then just just a final point
from you James we are in the midst of
one of the worst economic situations you
know well certainly in my lifetime uh we
don't see much Prospect of things
getting better in terms of energy prices
for quite some time
how long are we going to be in this
situation
look we we have a situation where they
have the highest inflation in 40 years
we have a huge huge shock to price of
energy but we also have the prices of
other things like food Rising incredibly
quickly now the government you might
think should be concentrating on that
but instead their focus on trying to
bring about sustainability to the public
finances so we're in a difficult
position but the key thing here is the
government mustn't try and bring about
that uh re return to credibility by
doing anything that makes the hits
during the tough winter ahead even
larger so avoiding cuts to working age
and pension benefits that will be so key
to people suffering with the cost of
living crisis is going to be a key thing
that the government must avoid
uh James Smith there from the resolution
Foundation great to have you on thanks
for being here
now the home office remember them
they're going to be in the high court
today after they were taken to court
over pre-settled status rules for EU
citizens the independent monitoring
Authority claims that 2.6 million EU
citizens are at risk of losing their
residency rights in the UK joining us
now Rhys Davis The General Counsel for
the independent monitoring authority of
the group which is taking the home
office to court uh lovely to have you on
the program this morning you're going to
have to explain from first principles
what is at risk here and why could we
see so many EU citizens living here in
the country you know shortly heading for
the exit of course so the EU settlement
scheme which is a scheme designed by the
UK government to implement the the
agreement reach between the EU and the
UK honest withdrawal from the EU
provides
um that a second application needs to be
made by individuals who have reached
five years or
sorry if they have five years residency
rights or less than five years residency
rise then they will not be able to be
eligible for settle status which is
permanent residents
so yeah so carry on please so it and in
which case they are required to make a
second application within five years of
their temporary right of residence
expiring so they're temporary writer
residence will expire after five years
if they fail to make that second
application they will lose their rights
irretrievably so they will lose their
right to live in the UK they will lose
their right to work in the UK has the
government not informed them that this
is the circuit these are the
circumstances in which they're existing
that is a that is an element of the you
settlement scheme so that is known as
part of the scheme however we feel that
the withdrawal beam which was reached
between the UK and the EU only provides
for the loss of Rights in Bay limited
circumstances that could be for example
a long absence from the UK what it
doesn't provide in our view is that you
will lose those rights if you fail to
make a second application which we feel
is not provided for at all individual
agreement so so what do you want uh that
this case to to achieve obviously this
is you're a quarter first instance I
suspect you'll be seeing this go all the
way to the Supreme Court now imagine you
might might feel the same but what would
you wish the high court and indeed
perhaps lit up further on down the line
what would you expect them or hope for
them to do well evidently there's a
difference in opinion between ourselves
and the home office so so the primary uh
aim for us is to see Clarity from the
court now that's Clarity for ourselves
for the home office but most importantly
it's for the EU citizens who will be
directly affected by this in the coming
years so yeah so what what can what kind
of effect would the loss of you know in
excess of 2.0 2.5 2.6 million EU
citizens what sort of effect would that
have on this country so well in terms of
the persons involved that will mean that
they will no longer have the right to
live and to work and to enjoy their
lives in the UK and so for those
individuals that that is a big issue for
them now we estimate there's around
upwards of two million people who will
be affected and that is a large cohort
of people now we would expect that a
number of those people would make a
second application but there is no
guarantee how many of those would
understand that that second application
is needed however fundamentally this
case is about whether they're entitled
to maintain those rights in the absence
of that second application why is it why
is it this why is this this sort of
Damocles almost hanging over them that
if they miss the opportunity if they
miss the application they don't get
another bite of the journey so so that
was a conscious Choice taken by the UK
government and how they designed the
scheme that implemented the withdrawal
agreement we don't believe that the
withdrawal agreement allows for that
process to to be to take place and
therefore that is why we've gone to
court to try and get clarity from them
at Chris Davis we will leave it there
and but I'm sure we'll be talking again
about this this one's got a bit to run
thanks very much for joining us
now do stay right where you are of
course a little early on this hour we
were speaking with the immigration
Minister Robert generic about the
situation at that manston Center he
believes that the conditions there are
not acceptable but doesn't believe that
it is not fit for purpose there are
things he believes that they can do to
improve the situation there however it
did rather feel when we were pushing at
the immigration Minister about comments
made by the Home Secretary in the House
of Commons yesterday about an invasion
on the south coast somewhat felt that he
might have disagreed anyway so Allah
Brahman clearly Under Pressure over
those comments about Asylum Seekers the
whole office has been told to get a grip
we'll get Labor's view after this
[Music]